and it's it seems like the only people
following the rules are what is
colloquially colloquially known as the
right but richie what did the new york
times say about you they called me a
writer that's right
and they knew it wasn't true right and
he punched well there's yes there's a
longer story there which we'll all
explain in um as i'm writing it down um
but basically what happened was that
they took a photograph of me
i have a certain appearance i assumed i
look a little bit like a knuckle dragon
neanderthal uh who would you know be
like one of those uh you know trump
supporting monkeys and so then they saw
the photo of me after being pepper
sprayed and they um you know took that
surface level
uh assumption but really if they have
looked you know even for 10 minutes they
would have realized that they were
allowed on my reporting in kenosha so
um really what it was there is oh he's
you know he's a writer he's a trump
supporter we don't even need to do our
due diligence because he's you know he
doesn't deserve and the photograph was
taken in front of that you know that
famous photo with the door punch
that was shattered
and they said who punched the door yeah
so if they if they said i mean can you
imagine my mom was so pissed she was
like who is give me that guys who's the
photographer no i'm just
i wrote a letter that i mean i wrote a
letter that night and a good friend of
mine talked me out of it because it
wouldn't have done richie anything so so
there's something called the gel man
amnesia effect this refers to when you
encounter a news story that you know to
be false yeah but then assume the news
in other areas is telling the truth
so you know what they said about your
own son right now imagine what every
story is like why assume any of the
other stories are true
well again i i would prefer
not to use these sweeping
generalizations
tim but i you know i'm listening
i just would like to figure out a way
that
there can be a more productive
conversation i mean
i don't know that you know when i was
marching in washington
going to arlington cemetery with we
carried coffins and you know it was a
very dramatic
effort
i'm not sure how many how many people we
alienated and how many people we sort of
um
corralled
but
it there just doesn't seem to be any
meeting of the ways anymore well the
right certainly is trying
again colloquially whatever you want to
call it the the
we've certainly reached out to tons of
people and you have this meme
ben shapiro yeah or saying debate me
debate me because
ben shapiro has consistently tried to
have sit down conversations with people
on the left they won't do it in fact so
it's true for him as well you're saying
oh this is a known issue right when when
ben shapiro went on this show he was
sitting next to a trans woman and he
when he gave his opinions the trans
woman grabbed him and threatened to put
him in the hospital
ben shapiro still will invite people to
to come
debate him or he you know to be fair ben
told us he's like i don't ask for
debates i ask for conversations and if
we argue we argue they won't do it when
he tried showing up to depaul in chicago
the police told him if he took one more
step he would be arrested because it's a
safety risk these people have been
burning down buildings to prevent
conversations we they threatened to burn
down the theater where we were hosting
our event
because they wanted to stop and it
worked the the theater said sue me i
don't care the damages i'd have to pay
you are cheaper than me rebuilding my
theater so we had to move the event
because there's a certain level of
threat and pressure that normal people
cannot tolerate
when when antifa is allowed to kill
these black lives matter rioters and
antifa their rioting resulted in the
death of between 26 and 32 people
and kamala harris
donated she solicited donations on
twitter to bail these people out of jail
joe biden's staff members solicited
donations or actually gave donations to
bail these people out
when you have
the january 17th rioters i'm sorry the
january 20th riders in 2017 trump's
inauguration
they they torched a limo that belonged
to an immigrant
they smashed a bunch of windows and when
the police arrested them
they
they all got off in fact not only did
they get off they sued dc and won
millions of dollars
so now you have somebody who owns a
venue and they get a phone call and they
say we're antifa and you know what will
happen they'll say anything you say
because the right isn't going to do this
the police also won't stop antifa
but if if a bunch of right-wingers go go
to the capitol they'll get a year in
solitary confinement if you get 90 to
100 plus days of left-wing extremists
fire-bombing a federal building in the
pacific northwest
where
a handful of these people get charged
for sure but only the ones who really
pushed the boundaries
for the most part like anybody anybody
who even walked in the building you know
befuddled are getting called a violent
terrorist extremist and having their
jobs destroyed a woman who didn't even
go in had her home raided in alaska
it's very obvious that when you know
bubba wasn't in bubba wallace yeah has
12 fbi gents or however many storm
nascar over a garage pole rope
but you can't get the fbi to investigate
you know very serious crimes like you
know
that we've seen with antifa then you
have to wonder uh i want to keep that
one a little vague but i've had my
dealings we're wondering like why isn't
uh you know with our security issues
where where's law enforcement like what
what was that there's an act
investigation maybe something will
happen but we've had death threats we've
had people call in fake swap police
raids to this building eight times and
the bomb squad has shown up it's
remarkable it's remarkable don't you
think the shoot like the shoe is kind of
on the other foot now though back in the
60s and 70s
it was all of these left-wing
progressive groups that were being
infiltrated by the authoritarian
government
it's not on the other foot it's i mean
well my point is is that now
it's the you know
that um
those groups aren't the ones that are
that are representing the same
existential threat that those people
were pro-free speech right and they were
anti-war which side is pro-free speech
and anti-war right now well that's yeah
so those who are for free speech the
rights of the people who are for pushing
back against corrupt corporate power and
war that would be described as today the
right
the left is
they're pro they're they're not
protesting uh i don't want to confuse
that protest we saw in the chamber
because that was that was debunked but
there are people outraged that
desantis stripped disney of their tax
privileges a massive multinational
corporation the left is like we should
give tax cuts these people should be
allowed ron desantis what he's doing is
wrong
just like
why are you cheering for the
corporations they're they're they're
outraged that uh elon musk wants to buy
twitter saying oh no we can't let
billionaires get social media but
they've been defending these same
billionaires for a decade
saying it's a private company they can
do what they want
so i i don't think i think left and
right are just
tribal signifiers we can call it up down
we can go left right we can call it a b
but it's not binary there's too many
there's so many different people with so
many different thoughts
if someone thinks that they're another
to you particularly for you if you're
like the left is horrible and that guy's
a leftist that guy's going to be like
well then dude i don't want to be near
you if you're going to call me that i'm
not ian i think you have an issue with
trying to dissect
for the sake of argument instead of
actually in uh engaging with the
argument well i think this is a part of
the reason why you're having trouble
inviting certain people on if you if you
predispose them as being part of this
evil idea or group then it's gonna be a
lot harder to get them to be like okay
he's cool well you are very passionate
about it tim it's true
so when
uh they post over like the young turks
right they just make things up
right
and i still they literally do and then i
don't engage with them and how often do
i say call out people's names and and
say them
infrequently maybe a couple times a week
or i usually say i don't want to say
their name yeah i don't want to minimize
harm when i privately reach out to them
they just say screw off
look man
i think there's a reality that you don't
want to acknowledge because
for whatever reason uh i i don't know
because you say this all the time like
oh we can't say left or right look
because mao did it you really want to be
like mao you're in the position of mao
right now you have that power that's a
ridiculous reduction you have a cultural
revolution of people that are listening
to you right now and and ian right see
what you're doing right now is you're
creating a false argument
no i'm this i'm very serious this
internet technology this guy did a thing
so if you do that thing it's the same
thing no you have that cultural power
that he had you have more power than he
had
i did not create the idea of leftists
existing
no no that was a french revolution thing
but but it's it's up to you man your
words are like
convincing people your issue is once
again semantics
definitely that's it or literally you
know whatever you want to call we should
move on i don't want to waste time
arguing the definitions of words that
don't actually add to the conversation
i'm saying if you if you divide people
then we're going to be living in a
divided society but if you unite people
then we will be united how do you unite
people by dispensing with these false
paradigms dichotomies left and right a
and b up and down people aren't black
and white
doesn't unr well we're in a paradigm
shift right so like some of our
definitions of things like left and
right republican and democrat are
changing and so i think a byproduct of
that is always going to be some degree
of uncomfortability where people are
like oh i'm outside of my comfort zone
this isn't exactly the way that i grew
up that i knew everything to be
so like on the one hand you're saying oh
we can't be using these terms because it
kind of casts people in these whatever
antiquated boxes
but also if you don't use words then how
can you communicate
you know any kind of ideas like about
these political
you know ideas like you have to put them
somewhere so like what would be your
solution there i think a lot of it is
communicating with emotions instead of
logic
how does that keep talking like like
you know you got to kind of understand
people and listen to them as they are
without labeling them
it's tempting to want to put people in
boxes so that you can understand them
maybe better but it's just about calming
people down really here i made a picture
nice there you go
magnetic field
it's a butt crack no it's uh
it's the left and the right
well turn it up turn it sideways now
what is it up down yeah it doesn't
matter i'll rip it in half what is it
then it doesn't matter what you want to
call it the point is what i'm showing
you here is there's many different lines
and there's many different points and
they're all very far away from each
other but some of them
there's there's still a very clear split
between the two groups but you'll notice
in the middle they overlap a little bit
the point is using using terms like left
and right as i often say are
not absolute which you seem to think
they are
it's a description of the spheres of
influence that exist and have a slight
merger at the point where there's
some you know maybe uh what do they call
it the stressed sideliners what pew pew
research called them
for the most part however everyone seems
to fall
on one side either by 0.1 degrees or by
100 degrees the fact remains left and
right are simply things we use to
describe the umbrellas that surround the
two different parent factions i thought
uh thomas massey came on the show a few
months ago and he was pretty said
something pretty profound he said in the
back of like the chamber where the
congress hangs out there's two dressing
rooms specifically like they built it to
have two political parties they do not
want more than that they want to
maintain this uniparty of duality by
keeping people like wild animals it's
like sports they want to be like two
teams trying to win well it's an easy
way to have a huge democracy where
people have the air of you know things
going back and forth when in reality
they're not so here's what happens right
people think that they you know
represent oh this side's fighting for me
but then in reality it's just two sides
that are basically so going in the same
direction so right now
leftists are posting
fake tweets
and fake quotes from me that say things
like tim poole has called for the death
of this person or that dude the other
day on tim's show he was saying that
people need to go out and get violent
against this group of people
and they believe it of course that never
happened right so what happens is the
people in that sphere of influence now
typically believe these things and it's
really remarkable when for some reason
conservatives think i'm an atheist which
i've never said and people on the left
claim that i'm
a far-right religious conservative
which i've also never claimed but a fair
point if you want if from your
perspective you want to think i'm more
religious because i do believe in god
but when they say things like
you know tim believes this thing about
taxes and i'm like every time i've
talked about taxes i've talked about
like the need for higher tax brackets
and a stronger progressive tax on the
wealthy even steve bannon said tax the
rich but they'll lie and make fake
quotes and then in that sphere of
influence which is absolutely split
between two parent umbrellas they all
believe that
so when i get into a conversation with
someone on the left which i recently did
he said something like you're pro
doxxing tim you would absolutely dox
antifa at a moment's notice i know what
you right-wingers do what does that mean
doxy uh docs means to publish the
private details of an individual like
their phone number their home their name
and i said no i actually have a huge
policy against that and i often avoid
saying names on my show to to prevent
what's called a brigade when everyone
targets an individual
and he was like no i heard you say he's
like i remember during occupy wall
street you were trying to film people's
faces and publish their names
and i said that never happened it was
yes it did everybody knows it because
they lied and made these things up
what really happened is during occupy
wall street i was walking down the
street and i saw three people wearing
masks deflating police tires and i was
filming so they attacked me and i said
transparency is what matters if
something is happening in public i'm
going to film it if you don't want your
identity revealed wear a mask
so what they did was okay
that's a tendent most people would
actually agree with if you are in the
public and you are causing damage we
have a right to know what you're doing
for whatever cause
you can wear a mask if you want to
protect your identity but if you're in
public during a protest doing these
things people will see you do it what
grounds do you have to violently assault
on someone who happens to have a camera
knowing that they have no winning
argument they changed it and just lied
and said tim poole was trying to take
their masks off and publish their names
interesting discussion and they also the
op the official occupy wall street
account tweeted tim poole just tried to
arrest someone which was an outright lie
and it was so egregious
that one of the other activist groups
matches them and said take that down now
like you went too far and they had to
remove it that's what happens when you
have control of the discourse right is
you can propagate whatever you want and
it won't you know like you were saying
with barack obama
blowing up an american citizen and not
being properly reported on
why my mom didn't know about it it's
like i was working at nbc during obama
at the end of obama's second term and it
was like the degree to which you know
these people had gotten their jobs in
the white house press corps specifically
because they asked all the right
questions you asked a question about
that drone blowing up that american
citizen in that white house briefing you
can say goodbye to asking any more
questions to the you know the press
secretary so it's like
after 40 years of us going like you know
kind of in the same direction left or
right it didn't matter because you had
this institution of the media that was
just wasn't going to question it thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm we'll see
you all there